pour depuis le mois de mars l'algérie a
beaucoup changé
mouvement populaire qui a rassemblé
pendant plus d'un an
des millions de personnes semblent
s'êtres volatilisés confinement
sanitaires imposées ici comme ailleurs a
eu un effet majeur les commerces restent
pour la plupart fermés les mesures
d'urgence ont été prolongées jusqu'au 15
juin et un couvre-feu est en vigueur de
17h15 et or le matin ce qui n'empêche
pas isson el qady de dénoncer la
situation de censure et l'arrestation de
nombreux journalistes dans le pays
le dernier en date c'est notre collègue
caldart nikhil présentateur vedette de
notre émission vedette le café presse
politique et qui a été embastillé à
exactement soixante jours pour pour
exercer son métier par laure la situer
correspondant tu n'existes pas le
correspondant de la chaîne française tv5
monde et de l'organisation reporters
sans frontières est en détention depuis
le 29 mars
il est accusé date est à l'unité
nationale
il avait simplement filmé rassemblement
dans le centre d'alger
selon ses avocats le journaliste risque
jusqu'à dix ans de prison où les
journaux et des sites d'information ont
aussi été verrouillée par le régime
la station privée radio m comme d'autres
est désormais interdite dans le pays les
algériens qui le peuvent
utilisent des réseaux sécurisés pour
continuer d'avoir accès à ces programmes
où on a compris que c'était à cause d'un
éditorial qui fait lui qui faisait les
bilans le bilan des 100 premiers jours
du président du mahdi des boulonnais qui
était un article critique de ses 100
premiers jours le ministre de la
communication a même évoqué la
possibilité d'une poursuite pour
diffamation parce qu'il considère que
l'article a été dit ferme at war moi
même j'ai enfin je suis celui qui a
signé cet article je l'assumé de boutons
book
les seules manifestations qui ont eu
lieu ce printemps à alger ont été
modestes et brèves
devant le tribunal où sont jugés des
activistes et des journalistes et des
militants convaincus c'est pas des
voyous c'est pas des des violences et
des gens qui ont des idées on peut être
d'accord ou pas
rien ne justifie l'emprisonnement pour
des derniers mois une bonne cinquantaine
de personnes ont été arrêtées pour
défaire relié à la révolte populaire
la plupart sont des militants qui ont
publié des messages de contestation sur
les réseaux sociaux et les sentences
sont lourdes
8 12 et même 18 mois de prison
c'est lourd c'est lourd surtout en ces
temps de corona nous algériens sont
particulièrement inquiet et l' envoi on
envoie des jeunes des pères de famille
en prison au profit du confinement qu'il
n'y ait pas de mobilisation pour
défendre ces personnes pour faire le
maximum d'exemple à ne pas suivre
l'élection controversée du président
abdel madjid de tebboune l'ancien
ministre du président déchu bouteflika
haredi le climat dans le pays
la population a compris que malgré le
faible taux de participation
cette élection imposé annonçait une
volonté de mettre fin à la contestation
populaire
et puis il la crise de lakovic 19 est
arrivé le régime souffle le chaud et le
froid
d'un côté les arrestations nombreuses
pour briller et de l'autre parfois la
libération avant terme de certains
militants politiques
dans mon cas évidemment là il y avait il
ya toujours un risque que cette
procédure ne débouche sur sur une
incarcération mais c'est pas cela qui
sait pas cela qui va nous faire reculer
en tant qu'équipe
en tant que collectif éditorial en tout
cas pour ma personne c'est pas ça qui va
me faire reculer dans l'exercice de ma
profession de journaliste je continuerai
à témoigner entre-temps radio m a perdu
plus de la moitié de son territoire et
les annonceurs commencent à manquer tous
les médias ont compris le message
les grands journaux ont accepté des
crocs premier ditoriaux pour rester en
vie
message de montréal pour adresser ma
solidarité et mon soutien à tous les
détenus politiques pour le moment la
plupart des algériennes aux plus
critiqué le régime
ce sont ceux de l'étranger qui
reprennent le flambeau regroupement
international récemment mis sur pied à
organiser un concert virtuel en appui
aux détenus d'opinion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le mouvement populaire du irak avait
obtenu le départ du président bouteflika
puis exiger une refonte de l'état et des
règles démocratiques
les manifestations vont reprendre vie a
aucun doute là dessus
un mouvement si vaste qu'il n'est
certainement pas disparu malgré les
effets de la pandémie il ya un gros
potentiel de combativité qui est
toujours en place et qui va s'exprimer
dès que les conditions sanitaires le
permettra
ils ont reçu